oh hi guys um so this is another quick
my hair I'm distracted okay um so I was
able to finally go pick up my packages
those guys uh from the place of mail the
peel box and so let's open them first
and foremost I got this tempur-pedic
discover wire our beds are rated number
one this oh um so what's in this I don't
know but let's open it up and see vamp
how are you guys what did you do today
yeah oh that's fun ooh it's um
what oh it's just a sample pack what the
who sent me this this is what their beds
are like great I can wash my kitchen
counters now Thank You tempur-pedic or
whoever sent this to me wait why why is
this why is this that and then happening
fun thank you whoo what's next okay
whoa this is a for real deal package and
I don't know who's it from Amazon and
it's amazon.com sent me this what from
Pennsylvania what is it what is it and
who is Oh little card big smile what oh
that's this Amazon's keep your gift a
surprise unwrap your presence before
opening this envelope Oh what did
someone buy me again there's a present
and it was it's a present
this is an actual present someone sent
me a present what is this hey grace I'm
a huge fan of your videos and a big
comedy nerd hope you don't have this but
if you do read gifting is cool with me I
live in Chicago and you and Michelle
should move here we all say the what oh
my god oh my god what this is so great
oh it's too much oh it's too much oh
it's too much and I'm opening the other
one and it's too much and it's too nice
oh my gosh it's too nice I have only
seen a few episodes of kids in the hall
and haven't seen all of them and this is
too much and too nice and you got what
is this second to none the 10th
anniversary special of it's his second
city Oh
the second city main stage company a
person is your name on this now I will
open the envelope that told me to wait
to open it oh these are gift receipts
why you person you did this so nice you
did this so nice and what is your name
oh it's probably on these things that
say the things no this one's empty and
it doesn't whoever this is from thank
you so much this is too nice and I am
overwhelmed and I'm overwhelmed thank
you so much oh my goodness oh my
goodness process I won't be able to
press the set for a little bit okay um
thank you thank you so much okay let's
see um
this is from who's this from Emma just
got a great name you
are you able to find those license
plates with your names on it very often
because this is a beautiful name
what do we got okay here's a letter and
it says dear Daily Grace encloses the
slide of mash a side of mash for your
birthday also included are some snaps
from a summer scooter run you have
pictures of your summers good of Oh
things pictures of places thank you for
those pictures and you found me roasted
garlic and Parmesan they rinse I'm gonna
make these I might eat them and then you
know what happens and that's so nice wow
thank you
this is how a dyslexic person sees it ah
sorry if you're dyslexic okay this is
from Amy MacDonald in North Vancouver
British Columbia
it's not even in England it's in Canada
I think isn't that weird
that's like we should put like a
California over in France somewhere
maybe there's fun read me I will do that
what does it say okay grace I thought
you could use something to organize all
the snow you've been getting so I made
you a clothespin card holder you can tap
onto your wall and feature some of your
favorite pal every week oh my gosh and
you made a diagram of how it works
that's so helpful because I wouldn't
know otherwise I'd be like why does this
[ __ ] semi Ali's clothespin it's just
kidding I mean that in the most
endearing way possible I might have just
broken your clothes pins go scissors do
what you are meant to do whoa
Oh feels good
whoa get into my possession quicker go
go to me oh my gosh oh my gosh look at
this little thing it says mail and it's
so great and you do you do it like this
and then something and then you put
these on different oh I see there
Austral on this is and it's good look
what's in there those guys are there
this is awesome thank you so so much Amy
MacDonald thank you
this is the sweetest little sweetest
little things oh my gosh oh and I'm so
overwhelmed oh okay this is from antonia
culture from germany oh my gosh I'll be
the vanes know how you say hello how you
guys say hello are you friends with
Heidi yeah beer and beer and pret
don't ruin this whatever it says oh my
gosh oh my gosh open to me beautiful
holy crap this is amazing this is my
face this is me giving the finger as a
bumble baby holding Bailey's and saying
what's up [ __ ] this is amazing thank
you so much for this holy crap you like
so much oh say I'm reading it my name is
Antonia I'm 16 and I'm from Germany
right like Heidi Klum one mind a few
weeks ago I posted this picture on
tumblr and you reblogged it so I decided
to give it to you hope you like it let's
gonna say this looks totally
Miller thank you so much that's so so
nice of you holy crap holy I am
overwhelming okay oh my gosh oh this is
another Amazon package oh no oh no from
Coffeyville Indiana no way is this a I
feel like I'm being Punk'd I feel like
my mom were saying that I feel like I'm
being Punk'd I think that's like a
parent thing to do to sound cool oh oh
and the presents oh who is this oh they
left a blank when people write their
names on it this is from is it the same
person that did the same thing I think
it mrs. sim you got me
Monty Python and the Flying Circus
collector's edition holy crap
thank you oh oh oh oh I'm so overwhelmed
and I want to say thank you to you guys
it's so so nice of you and I don't know
ah thank you
this is so nice oh my gosh I'm gonna go
thank you guys bye